à nola rae et consorts c'est juste du
bashing idiot on n'est pas obligé de
faire de la télé réalité
ou de faire du télé bashing pour mashing
à la télé plutôt comme cyril hanouna et
ses chroniqueurs quotidiennement pour
faire des bons scores en titane je ne
savais pas
j'ai rien contre eux c'est ce style de
télé que je déteste
[Musique]
pascal je te laisse avec gilles à ce que
je peux dire juste un truc un truc à ce
site a droit à l'avocat de mon pote 12,2
pour mes fantaisies vas-y non mais bien
un truc venant que gilles à trahison
suprême et ce à trois sont tellement ce
que tu fais selon gilles verdez je suis
très content que tu ne restes pas notre
émission ce soir ça va très bien mais
j'ai découvert regardera avec passion
elle regarde pas voilà et que tu sais
très bien que parce qu'elle réagissait à
l'époque comme tout on fait tous le pied
bien télé parce que toi même et enora
malagré vous passez votre temps à dire
du mal de lui à l'époque voilà point
barre et un jour il a un peu réagi une
aura qu'on embrasse voilà oui bien sûr
on la jambe combat
[Rires]
serrés contre pascal louis pascal way
de machines à l'époque rappelle plus
j'étais fâché à l'époque il tâchait
bas enora malagré notamment en fait ça
fait celui-là tu as vu j'avais grossi
c'est vrai que tu es mieux là ouais
merci non mais il n'aura qu'une amie
puis noire on l'aimé pour ça dans
l'émission oui mais n'aurait donc j'ai
déjà dit mais à l'époque une émission
avec karine ferri sur tmc et les 30
extraordinaire formidable c'est plus le
pronostic bref une émission de ce soir
est donc et donc c'est vrai qu'on était
un peu attaquées sévèrement parfois par
certains de tes chroniqueurs qui ne nous
avaient pas et qui s'en prenait
notamment au physique ce que j'ai jamais
apprécié moi dans la vie voilà et c'est
vrai que alors tu connais en plus le
principe de ces émissions autre fait
réagir mais néanmoins ce que j'ai dit je
sais les deux mois ce que j'ai dit je
l'assumé parce que moi j'assume toujours
ce que je dis c'est vrai que je trouvais
qu'il y avait dans ton émission et dieu
sait tu sais que je t'aime et tu sais
qui a fait ça fait l'otan tuent leur
rappeler qu'on veut de produire enroulée
de produire quand on était producteur
alors que on n'était pas nombreux à
reconnaître ton talent à l'époque et
c'est bien dommage mais voilà il ya des
gens dont on émission dont je pense
qu'ils passent leur vie effectivement à
faire du bashing il existe en faisant du
bashing sur les autres sans avoir jamais
rien fait de leur vie gilles verdez
et
m
incroyable je finis à paris l'a jamais
fait grand chose heureusement que tu es
là pour le mettre en lumière depuis des
années
d'excès on vous dit
on mais aujourd'hui tout n'est pas fini
mais je dis ça de très bonne humeur il
ya aucun souci ouais c'est vrai qu'on
tend
le lonsois de réserver mon créneau je
regarde le bouton home et j'ai très bien
jeter ralala et je t'expliquerai l'échec
s'est créé ce qui se passe si tu veux
mais en l'occurrence ce jour là j'avais
été bâchée très violemment la veille et
j'ai mon boulanger le matin qui me dit
parce que j'avais pas regardé l'émission
qui me dit t'as vu ce qui s'est passé
hier et ses élus ont du coup j'ai
regardé et il ya quelqu'un qui va pas
elle qui me dit t'as vu j'ai su a été
descendu en flammes par enova et enora
malagré est défendue par un gérard
louvin parce que gérard était dans ton
émission et avait dit à irin aura mais
de quel droit tu oses juger quelqu'un
qui a fait quand même beaucoup de choses
à la télé avec laurent frontère etc et
il m'a dit heureusement que ce n'était
pas l' inverse et il avait raison en
fait alors qu'elle était dans son rôle
et à l'été elle était incroyable comme
chroniqueuse et gilles je vous le dis
franchement etc voilà c'est pour moi
c'est une pièce maîtresse de l'émission
vraiment direct le sait et il est
tellement gentil dans la vie oui mais
c'est vrai qu'il a pas fait grand chose
à damas il
était rédacteur en chef du parisien il a
il a écrit ya plein de livres il a une
coiffure incroyable
et maintenant vous êtes fragile s'est
arrêté gilles c'est un monument mais
voilà le visiter mais cet harmonieux bah
oui je le dis voilà je me dis bon en
tout cas c'est ce soir un bon rythme
tout va
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
pas con patients
pendant qu'est ce qui se passe parce
qu'elles n'ont je dis tu vois je suis là
ce soir je dirais oui bah oui bah oui
bah oui bah oui ça la raison
on